Selam i'm Jamshid el jem CD and this is
a Mideast minute villagers thank you for
tuning in as always from the middle east
today and as we broadcast to you live
from Omaha the hometown of a number of
peacekeepers with Donald Trump's
election win leading to worries our
borders will close it's time for the
middle east to realize that immigrating
to the United States is overrated the
United States a nation built by
immigrants when making it was as easy as
boarding a ship but no more making it in
modern America is hard so hard in fact
that immigrating to America is the last
thing you'd want first of all according
to the Economist housing prices in the
United States are nearing an all-time
high if you can't afford to buy a house
what are you gonna do this Fox's David
Asman explains it's not as if people are
trying to just give them away the houses
in Detroit were literally being sold for
a dollar each and now they can't even
give houses away
yes exactly people are trying to just
give them away but what good is a house
if you have no job according to the
Bureau of Labor Statistics the
unemployment rate in the United States
is at four point six percent which
sounds very low but is actually eighty
four percent higher than 1953 which
means jobs are difficult to come by just
listen to this business owner on KCRA
could you use more workers oh definitely
there's a real surgit right now
especially skilled workers yes exactly
there is an urgent need for workers but
what good is a job and a house without
food on your plate according to the US
government's National integrated drought
information systems droughts are
currently affecting 26 percent of the
United States devastating farmland and
making food hard to come by
Alison Aubrey at PBS reports 40 percent
of all the food produced in the United
States never gets eaten
yes exactly the United States has so
much food even droughts aren't an issue
is that the kind of country you want to
immigrate to one with houses to give
jobs in abundance and so much food we
throw tons in the trash that sounds
awful and regardless villagers we barely
have space
we're packed to the gills you'd last a
week in New York before you wished you'd
never left the wide open vistas you call
home I'm Jeff seid al-jabr City and this
has been a Mideast minute
[Music]